now to a heartbreaking story the
University of Virginia says all three
students who were shot to death Sunday
night played for the School's football
team police allege they were killed by a
fellow student and former player who was
arrested yesterday after an hours-long
Manhunt officials say the suspect had
shown signs of trouble senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge is at the UVA campus in
Charlottesville Virginia Catherine good
morning
Nate two students remain in the hospital
and classes are canceled for a second
day police have not released a motive
but we are hearing directly from a
student who says she was there when the
shots rang out
at the football stadium students laid
flowers at a makeshift Memorial to their
classmates they were really important to
the UVA Community as an eyewitness to
the shooting comes forward so we thought
he was going to shoot everyone in the
bus at that point sophomore Ryan Lynch
says the charter bus with about two
dozen UVA students and a professor was
pulling into a campus garage at the end
of a field trip when she alleges the
suspect Christopher Darnell Jones Jr
confronted one of the football players
he was like
um you're all you guys are always
messing with me said something weird
like that but it was very bizarre
because they didn't talk to him the
whole trip then Lynch alleges Jones
started shooting they just kept coming
more and more gunshots the shooter just
kind of walked or like skipped off the
bus three UVA football players were
killed second year wide receiver Devin
Chandler was an honor roll student who
had previously played at Wisconsin third
year wide receiver Lavelle Davis Jr was
a three-star recruit from South Carolina
he had just won a scholarship for the
school year and fourth year linebacker
DeSean Perry hailed from Miami Florida
another three-star recruit who majored
in studio art we just received
information the suspect is in custody in
an emotional moment during a live news
conference Monday the UVA police chief
Tim Longo confirmed Jones capture after
a more than 12-hour Manhunt
authorities detailed recent complaints
about Jones possessing a gun in
September though a weapon was not found
as well as an alleged hazing incident
but in that case the witnesses did not
cooperate he was still a student but to
my knowledge he was no longer on the
football team and hadn't been on the
team for over a year the suspect
s for Jones senior said the last time he
talked to his son he seemed paranoid
what happened uh why did that to get
this far
he could have called me
authorities say the initial charges of
second-degree murder will likely be
upgraded as investigators learn more
about the attack and the suspect's
intent Tony
Catherine thank you very much heartbreak
all the way around all the way around
the people on the bus yeah who witness
it they will never be the same I saw the
father saying later that his son had
told him some guys are messing with him
whatever that means whatever happened it
doesn't justify that it definitely does
not and this is the University of
Virginia these these kids are living
their parents dreams and they're they're
at the beginning of the rest of their
lives and think about those parents
they're sending their baby off to
college you expect them to come back
with a degree yeah and live the rest of
their life that's right sad all right
Catherine thank you again